we
[music] are the
multinational people of the Russian
Federation,
united by a common destiny
on our land,
these are the first lines of the fundamental law of the
Russian constitution, and
every word is filled with deep meaning,
has great meaning on our land,
united by a common destiny, people probably
thought and were guided by this
when they went to a referendum in the Crimea and
Sevastopol
March 18, 2014 they lived and live on
their land and wanted to live a common destiny
with their historical homeland from Russia
they had every right to do so and achieved
their goal,
first of all, we congratulate them on the holiday,
this is their holiday, we congratulate them
precisely to save people from these sufferings
from  of this genocide is the main
main reason, the motive and the
purpose of the military operation that we launched
in the Donbass and Ukraine, this is precisely the
goal and here, you know, the
words from the Holy Scripture come to my mind
there is no more love,
as if someone gave their soul for
friends of their start operations coincided
committed  but it coincided by chance with the
birthday of one of our outstanding
military commanders,
canonized as saints, Fedor
Ushakov, who in his entire brilliant
military career did not lose a single
battle, he once said that
these thunderstorms would go to the glory of Russia, so
it was then,
so it is today and so it will always be
thanks
and the best confirmation of this is
how our guys fight, how to act
during this military operation, shoulder to shoulder
help support each other, and if
necessary,
since they cover their brother with their
body from a bullet on the battlefield
, we haven’t had such unity for a long time it
happened that we started  operation
coincided quite coincidentally coincided with
the birthday of one of our distinguished
military
[music]
[applause]